hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 4 episode to recap and
review we got some answers that ask some
questions then a slow simmering kind of
character based episode and then a last
minute reveal that has major
implications for the rest of the story
if you haven't watched episode 2 of mr.
robots fourth season which is titled 402
payment required then this video will be
filled with spoilers and it's not for
you hit the subscribe button go watch
the episode and then come back for this
because we're gonna talk about
everything that happened for everyone
else let's get into it four words in a
room we've seen before no the other one
imaginary magda Alderson an imaginary
younger Elliot knows something that we
don't based on the end of episode 2 it's
something that mr. robot and Elliot
don't know either there's another
personality lurking inside Elliot and
that is the bomb that this episode
dropped and Wow that's a lot to think
about this isn't an idea that hasn't
come up over and over in series Sam s
Mel told The Hollywood Reporter in an
interview that he scans the forums and
he hasn't seen this particular twist
guessed correctly yet since this is the
thing that's on everybody's minds I
promise that we'll come back to it at
the end of the video and we'll talk a
lot more about it and more about what
Sam said in that interview but a lot of
other things did happen in this episode
and we can't just overlook them so first
and foremost we get an education on the
dais group from Phillip price the
sequence of events picks up right after
he revives Elliot the sequence really
brought home to me how well this show is
put together because let's face it this
could have easily come off as lame or
cheesy if they didn't get it absolutely
right
I think they pulled it off and in the
process of that we learned that in 1989
after the fall of the Berlin Wall a
young imaginative Minister Jiang aka
White Rose saw a possibility for a new
world order
Jane created an investment group with a
goal of bringing together the world's
wealthiest and most powerful men to
consolidate control and manipulate
events for profit turns out that a
younger White Rose
very good at recruiting and the
potential profits were such that they
trumped anybody's moral reservations
about being involved in these kinds of
activities what the group members
including price failed to recognize
though was that white rose had a bigger
plan in mind
a secret billion dollar project which we
know is under the Washington Township
plant where Elliott's father worked that
project which we can't say for sure what
it is is currently being shipped off to
the Congo and when that happens price
and Elliott will no longer be abuse for
white rose in his story about the dais
group and how they came together there's
a truckload of exposition for us as
viewers and Elliott who is essentially a
dead man walking
Ecore panned the dark army were on the
radar but this is the first introduction
of dais
fortunately for Elliott all roads lead
back to White Rose which is where all
his energy has been focused anyway but
the group makes her seem even more
powerful if that's possible as we watch
the clips with her shaking hands with
world leaders Elliott and contrast is
sitting in his old office at allsafe
which is kind of boarded up and
abandoned he's essentially talking to
himself as he talks to mr. robot so even
though price decides to help him the
odds are completely stacked against
these two elsewhere we do see that Dom
has followed Janice's directions and
made it to her meeting about the
Santiago case the way this scene played
out really worked for me as I bought her
performance and thought she was actually
turning on the dark army as that was
playing out this doesn't turn out to be
the case though rather she's just
feeding the investigating agent a dark
army approved cover story about Santiago
working with a drug cartel
Janice is awesome again she continues to
carve out a space in the story at the
late stage that she's entered it when
Dom says she can only be 99% certain
that they bought her story the agent
dies it's made to look like a suicide
but it's clear that the dark army made
this happen he's thrown from his balcony
at his apartment or hotel or whatever it
was and I just have to point it out once
again DOM does a fantastic job here and
her situation is really emphasized here
it kind of gets put in the background of
the big story that's going on but the
dark army is really putting the squeeze
on her Elliott is also up against the
clock here we know there's 8 days until
the project ships he needs White Rose to
bring the Deus group together price
helps out with this he goes and meets
with White Rose tells them he's going to
resign and that they have to replace him
we learned that they have to get the
whole group together in order to do that
before he goes and does that we learned
that Susan Jacobs who Darlene killed
obviously in season 2 was his connection
with the banking so while price goes off
to meet with White Rose Elliott tries to
figure out how to get a hold of Susan
Jacobs in episode 1 Elliott and Darlene
were at odds with each other
she was self-medicating and accusing him
of shutting down in response to Angela's
death we find out in this episode that
their mother has died which ultimately
brings them back together
it's a strange term but I think it's an
interesting one because Elliott is
laser-focused here the stakes are life
and death for him and his sister she
doesn't know that yet but he has to take
time out they both do to deal with this
real family situation and of course they
don't like their mother their mother was
not a good parent but we get some good
character moments with them here
especially when they listen to the tape
and what this whole sequence this whole
situation of dealing with her in the
funeral home it really built anxiety
like as a viewer for me I was anxious
that like the episode was gonna come to
an end and I knew something was gonna
have to happen so I think it ultimately
worked for me but it felt strange when I
was watching it the first time it does
serve the purpose of getting Darlene and
Elliott together I think that's a good
thing
I think Darlene brings some humanity
into the situation where Elliott's just
only focused on what he's thinking and
what he's trying to do I think what she
says is important as well he does need
her in order to do this like I mentioned
a few minutes ago the odds are
completely stacked against these guys so
they're able to take care of the
situation with their mother they're able
to talk about Angela and get that out in
the open
now they're both working together which
is a good thing
Elliot learns that she killed Susan
Jacobs and he's upset at first but he
forgives her for doing what she did
because of the things that Susan Jacobs
did in relation to the Washington
Township case as they're talking she
mentions that Veera is back which we saw
in the post credit scene of season
three's finale she also mentions when
she brought up Vera's return to Eliot he
brushed it all this leads to Eliot and
mr. robot having a confrontation where
they both say that they don't remember
the conversation and it opens the door
to there being another personality with
whom Angela had told this information to
then we cut back to the boardroom where
Eliot first had his meeting with Tyrell
there we find his mother and a younger
version of himself there's a table that
has four chairs there we find out that
they're waiting for someone they're not
waiting for Elliot they're not waiting
for mr. robot they're waiting for the
other one and that brings us to the end
of the episode and to the big question
of who is the other personality I think
it's interesting here how they
introduced that like we had a Corp and
the dark army and now we learned that
there is a Deus group that's behind them
in the same way we had Elliot and mr.
robot they were at odds with each other
but then we also learned that there's
another personality that's another layer
beyond them so there's a pretty nice
parallel between those two situations
there in the beginning of the series
Elliot told us there was a powerful
group of people running the world now at
the beginning of season four we find out
about this Deus group who fit this
opening description from the pilot to a
tee there's a powerful group of people
out there that are secretly running the
world
I'm talking about the guys no one knows
about the guys that are invisible the
top 1% of the top 1% the guys that play
God without permission it's nice to go
back to the beginning and to get this
reveal to speculate about but if I'm
being honest I don't have a good guess
at what is happening my first thought
was that we are the other personality
Eliot talks to us as his imaginary
friend
are plenty of reasons why that wouldn't
exactly make sense in the hollywood
reporter interview s mail says that this
idea was baked in since the beginning of
the story he says when it's revealed
that we will absolutely be able to go
back through the series and see it he
says and I'm quoting here I think it's
one of those things where if we did our
job right it's a balance of it feeling
inevitable but also unexpected and
surprising that's what we're going for
we don't want to be too much of a shock
where it's just a gotcha and a gimmick
type of twist moment we wanted to feel
earned because the answer should make
sense
you guys could technically figure it out
because it's been in the show the whole
time we're excited to see it play out so
now the table is officially set and it
looks like Sam in the writers room have
strived to keep it a hundred percent
this episode had a little bit of
everything there were some funny parts
slipped in there with Darlene and Eliot
cremation cardboard coffin your cheapest
urn the guy in the snowman costume
offering condolences Dom situation on
the other hand is not funny
it's the pressure cooker where her
family will pay if she doesn't perform
for the dark army and Janice really adds
some color they're learning about Deus
is satisfying and it makes you wonder
how things will shake out for price it's
unlikely that this new Alliance is going
to end well for both price and Elliot
and as viewers do we actually want to
see the guy who was the face of evil
Corp get a happy ending
birra has yet to make an appearance but
we at least have some context around the
end credits scene now he's been in both
the trailers so I'm sure it's just a
matter of time until we see the brave
traveler inject himself into the current
events we also didn't get any Tyrell but
he should also make a return rather soon
episode 2 was another great looking
episode there were good character
moments with Elliot and Darlene enough
mystery to go around wTF is going on in
that boardroom and where exactly is that
going down I mean it's in Elliott's head
but where does the body if you get where
I'm coming from there's so much to think
about so much to discuss let me know in
the comments what you think's going on
and where things are headed there are
plenty of details for us to discuss and
I'll be interested to see what you guys
are thinking please like the video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel
if you haven't already thanks for
watching we'll talk to you soon